have you seen the britney documentary um
no jessica simpson hasn't watched
framing britney spears
and has no plans too it definitely
gives me anxiety and i i lived it in an
appearance on tamaran hall
airing friday jess says it would be too
hard to watch the documentary about
britney
and to relive that time of course both
pop stars made their debuts
in the late 90s and soared to
superstardom in the early 2000s
it was feeling that way i had the weight
literally of the world
on me not only does the pop star turned
fashion designer say she
lived it she says she knows brittany and
watched it all happen
in real time i know brittany and i know
what
she went through and it's so it's so
hard
because it's so many people's opinions
on you just trying to live your life as
a as a normal human being because inside
we're really just
you know we're we are normal you know at
the end of the day
the 40-year-old mogul understands why
britney and other big stars
eventually put a wall up we might have a
big
platform but um you know
you can only take stuff for so long you
can only
you know allow people
in and attacking you until you have to
really
you know put your guard up and while
justin timberlake has
publicly apologized to his ex brittany
following the doc's release
for benefiting from a system that
condones misogyny
jess doesn't necessarily think she's
owed an apology from one of
her most famous exes john mayer who made
some public
now infamous comments about their past
sex life
in the memoir if i'm going to talk about
stuff that
caused me pain i'm going to be honest
about it and that was a time in my life
where i was very manipulated
and very also like in love or
seemingly and now that i
have the love of eric it's just such a
different
thing and i i wouldn't
expect an apology in fact the happily
married mom of three
doesn't even think there's a need for an
apology i don't know i feel like people
end up
finding their way to uh
let you know they're sorry i mean he
might not be sorry and
that's okay like we weren't even we were
kind of like
on off on off at that time so
but like to talk about anybody sexually
kind of disrespectful
but i mean that's on him in jessica's
2020 memoir open book
she opened up about her relationship
with john whom she dated on
and off following her 2005 divorce from
nick lachey
revealing their contact ended in 2010
after he told playboy that she was quote
sexual napalm
and when eti caught up with jess this
week to talk about the paperback edition
of her book
which includes some past journal entries
jess said it helped her gain more
perspective
on some of the more challenging times in
her life whether i was mad at myself in
a moment whether i was heartbroken
whether i was confused i just think
owning all those
emotions on paper and confronting them
is so important so
in choosing those journal entries
it kind of was like i re you know it's
just like i just had to like
pick like it wasn't it wasn't i have to
use this one
you know some i was like oh
is that one too intimate or oh no
it's okay i can do this yeah